bonjour gérard respire merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur rt france alors on
l'a dire différentes attaques et qui met
le feu aux poudres comment peut-on
qualifier actuellement les relations
entre la turquie et l'irak
là les relations et la présence et
l'action militaire irakienne en turc par
l'ong turque en irak remonte déjà à
quelques temps même sous saddam hussein
à la turquie avait quelques postes
militaires en dans la région kurde
irakienne bon donc depuis effectivement
que les kurdes ont joué un rôle
militaire important dans le conflit en
syrie et donc à la tension permanente
des kurdes en turquie à la turquie a
pris des décisions d'intervention
militaire a donc il ya quelques jours
ils ont frappé a été tué sept membres
kurdes d'une milice qui est en iran
puisque le kurdistan et est à cheval
entre plusieurs pays et il y a deux
jours effectivement à je pense que paris
par erreur de jugement ils ont à tuer
des officiers irakiens qui sortait d'une
réunion avec des membres du pkk donc
d'un parti cudos aux kurdes auquel il
s'oppose alors l'egypte le koweit la
jordanie et l'arabie saoudite qui ont
toutes été en tous été contactés par
l'irak afin de faire front commun pour
faire plier la turquie est ce que la
stratégie de bagdad peut-elle
être payante dans un premier temps à
bagdad a souhaité une réponse
bilatérales puisqu'elle a annulé la
visite du ministère de l' du ministre de
la défense turc en irak et a demandé aux
l'ambassadeur turc à bagdad de devenir
au ministère des affaires étrangères
pour discuter de cette situation là donc
bilatéralisme mais dans un deuxième
temps effectivement la stratégie
irakienne peut être multilatérale a en
demandant à la ligue arabe de prendre
position
un globalement donc il ya une
possibilité non pas d'escaladé militaire
mais d' escalade diplomatique
qu'est ce qui se joue stratégiquement
sur le terrain pour la turquie pourquoi
elle ne veut-elle pas céder à parce que
d'abord cette sa vision je dirais
d'expansionnisme régionale globale a
depuis quelque temps là à turquie à une
des facilités et une petite base au
qatar donc dans le cadre d'une réunion à
politique d'une proximité politique via
les frères musulmans avec le qatar est
là cette présence en syrie cette
présence en irak
la présence que nous lui connaissons
depuis quelque temps en libye son
activisme en méditerranée orientale donc
au nom de cet expansionnisme là à
erdogan soit effectivement recueillir
dans sa politique et dans un soutien
interne
son activisme externe est ce que ces
pressions justement avec avec la turquie
peuvent déstabiliser l'irak
on le rappelle le premier ministre
mustapha el kamouni 10000 s'est engagé à
organiser des élections anticipées après
la révolte commencé en octobre dernier
je pense pas qu'il y ait un impact de
cette situation dure que vis-à-vis de la
situation purement irakienne qui est
effectivement difficile d'un point de
vue sanitaire avec le
12h19 difficile ô combien un point de
vue économique avec la baisse des
exportations de pétrole
difficile par les problèmes de
ressources en eau difficile avec le vécu
auprès de son voisin iranien
donc là l'interface entre la la turquie
et l'irak ne pèse pas grand chose dans
la situation intérieure irakienne
ce sont plutôt les éléments purement
irakien qui permettront faire des
arbitrages politiques et est ce que la
communauté internationale pourrait
éventuellement réagir ces tensions entre
les deux pays
dans un premier temps je pense que nous
serons en termes d'européens
observateurs il faut laisser à bagdad le
soin d'intervenir donc comme je
l'expliquais au niveau bilatéral entre
les deux pays
deuxièmement de mettre en place sa
propre stratégie un multilatérales avec
l'araignée guerrab éventuellement est
effectivement ainsi il y avait soit une
décision négative ou positive de la
ligue arabe de soutenir une demande du
retrait turc
il serait à ce moment-là possible pour
l'europe d'intervenir au point de vue de
prises de position merci beaucoup gérard
vespière d'avoir été avec nous à cet
après midi sur rt france rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur associé à la fée mot
la fondation à d'études pour le
moyen-orient merci beaucoup